une apostasie guillerette associée au
passaggio criminel grave considère
économique mon miel hurlant -
coochie-coochie-
coo  fais-le te mettre à la maison
fais-moi à la maison prêt à aller tuer
ton premier cerf de Virginie tu sais que
ce ne sera pas la meilleure vidéo que nous ayons
jamais faite
je ne peux pas croire que tu es à ton
premier appel Caroline père  apprendre à
leurs fils à chasser comme un rite de passage
aussi vieux que le temps je me considère toujours plus comme
un gars de Marriott le soleil quand vous
voyez votre premier cerf de Virginie, ça
va avoir l'air tout mignon et moelleux nous pouvons
honorer le cerf mais nous pouvons '  t love it
dinde panini les paninis sont de bonnes bosses sur
le cerf ce cher
[Musique]
allons-y tu sais pourquoi j'aime ces
bois ici il n'y a rien pour me déranger
[Musique]
quand tu trouves un cerf tout
se met en place il ne le fait pas  Prends Don maintenant
il ne pourra jamais pourquoi es-tu  enregistrer ce
Don cela fait partie du récit, je
craignais juste que cela ne fasse une bonne
crise à mi-parcours augmenter les enjeux de la
caméra de Don essayant d'avoir un moment avec mon
fils à droite maman Greg dit que je pourrais me
calmer tu as appelé Greg papa ouais mais seulement
comme cinq fois la première fois que j'ai rencontré ma
petite amie, elle est comme si j'étais un
mécanicien certifié une infirmière autorisée non mon départ
ouais eh bien devinez ce que j'ai eu un camion cassé
dans un problème cardiaque
vous et moi avons fait des choses dont la loi
se souviendra longtemps  vers le bas, mais
je pense que vous devriez probablement couvrir la plupart
de ces choses de l'autre côté du
pont là-bas, vous voulez que je traverse le
pont en premier, donc je suis couvert par vous
testant le pont avant que quelqu'un ne le
traverse à cause d'un saint exactement
ne le faites pas  t'inquiète j'ai Jésus
toi